so right now in Washington DC there's
this thing going on called the planetary
defense conference that is actually what
it's called at the beginning of the
conference
NASA Administrator Jim bridenstine said
this this is not about Hollywood it's
not about movies this is about
ultimately protecting the only planet we
know right now to host life in
scientists there are laser focused on
figuring out one thing how to dodge an
asteroid it is currently hurtling
directly at earth here's the thing
that asteroid it's not real so why are
the scientists pretending that it is
find out we talked to her I'm Kathy
Cosco I'm a planetary scientist at Los
Alamos and I use supercomputers to model
what happens when an asteroid or a comet
hits the earth and how to stop one from
hitting the earth and so just like you
have a fire drill just like when you sit
down on a plane they tell you about the
oxygen masks and all of that we practice
this every two years because we learn
from practicing we learn from our
mistakes why is this coming up now right
it's like as you said these events and
then of themselves or we expect to be
pretty rare so that's why now we are
doing this now because this is the first
time we've really been capable of doing
this and we've been bust a few times so
you know you can't deflect a tornado or
a hurricane right now
you can't glue a fault shut so the San
Andreas doesn't have earthquakes anymore
we can't do that yet but with an
asteroid or a comet it looks like we're
pretty much there there's some
technology that needs to be developed
yet and there's a few things we still
need to learn about how these objects
are composed and how they respond to
being hit by a kinetic impactor or being
ablated by potentially a standoff
nuclear device or shot with a laser the
things that we're looking at it as
mitigation techniques we still need to
study that very carefully and that's why
we're doing a lot of this on computer
it's because if they go sideways I can
push delete and go home for dinner
so it's a much better thing to do a lot
of this homework affords an issue what
are the actual chances of a near Earth
object breaking through the atmosphere
actually making impact here on the
ground we actually get hit every night
if you go and go to a place where the
sky is dark and look up you're gonna see
meteors even on a night when it's not a
meteor shower and so we get this
constant rain of space dust coming at us
all the time so you have something like
the air burst that happened in Russia a
few years back those happen maybe once
every 70 to 100 years we think maybe
medium-size like meteor crator happen
maybe every like 50 hundred thousand
years really big things like the one
that killed the dinosaurs every 100
million years bigger than that maybe
only a couple of times in the history of
the planet
can you explain what happened in Russia
in Chelyabinsk and why that was unique
they were actually very lucky the
Chelyabinsk object the meteoroids that
came in was about 70 metres across at
the top of the atmosphere
it was very fragile so it broke apart
and it actually exploded three times on
the way down and part of the reason it
did that was that it came in at a very
shallow angle and so it had a longer
path through the atmosphere to deposit
its energy a sort of air break that
could have been much much worse for the
people living in Chile events if it had
come in at a steeper angle and had more
of its energy focused on the city they
don't hit that often but we live in a
shooting gallery these things are
whizzing past us all the time so back in
the 90s there was the shoemaker-levy 9
comet it went so close to Jupiter it got
torn apart into a bunch of different
pieces but then came back and hit
Jupiter and we watched that very
carefully and people modeled that at the
time people are still studying that
event there was asteroid Apophis that
made a close approach while I was in
grad school and I will never forget that
day my whole life because Apophis is a
big object it's hundreds of meters
across
it's a rubble pile so it's a challenging
one to deflect in 2004 when it came by
us it was a very close approach to the
earth and its orbit was not very certain
at the time and there was a particular
point in space that if the center of
mass went through
this little one meter keyhole the the
Earth's gravity would have worked on it
enough that it would bring it back
around to strike us in 2029 so we were
sitting in lab that day we all skipped
class and sat there frantically
reloading the NASA website waiting to
see what that trajectory was fortunately
for all of us it did not go through the
keyhole it is not going to hit the earth
in 2029 but it is coming back that was
also a wake-up call in 2004 and that's
when a lot of these meetings kicked off
and they've been building steam ever
since let's say this was not a drill and
you know we do detect a near-earth
object and it is months away from wiping
out a US state what what what are some
of our options what can we do to deflect
it months away is a really bad day and
so if you've got something with only a
few months morning that's a tough one to
deal with at that point you're looking
at a lot of evacuation with maybe six
months warning you if you're real lucky
and there's some science mission or
other spacecraft that's getting wrapped
and stacked and ready to go out you
might be able to send some sort of
nuclear device with it but that's that's
a big reach because you have to prepare
that sort of mission extremely carefully
and so six months might not be enough
time to turn that around even when we
talk about short warning times we're
talking about a decade it takes years to
prepare a spacecraft to design it to get
it ready to build it to field it to
launch it and then it takes years to get
it out into deep space to where it needs
to be to do the deflection you're
talking about something that's loading
out in space that's the size of the
Empire State Building potentially and
you've got to push that thing around to
get it off of Earth's orbit and so let's
say we do have a longer runway you
mentioned using a nuclear device for
example to divert its course we have a
bunch of options that we're considering
and it's very dependent on what the
contact
is what kind of object is it how big is
it how soon is it coming and these are
all of course hypotheticals for a
nuclear device you have two options like
roasting a marshmallow you can either
stick it in the fire or you can hold
back get the lighter brown color on the
marshmallow depending on whether you
like it crispy or not right with the
nuclear standoff burst you how close you
are to the object determines how much
energy you're gonna source into it and
you vaporize a thin layer off the
surface and then that comes off and
pushes it the other direction if you
need to destroy the object and disperse
the fragments then for example if it's
something really really big like if it
were a kilometer across then you might
need to do this then you can actually
detonate the nuclear device much closer
in and potentially destroy it disperse
it no other options people are looking
at lasers as another option the
challenge with that one as they've
reported so far I'm not working on this
project is keeping the optics clean so
you're you're flying through this cloud
of vapor that you're roasting off the
surface and it keeps just plating onto
the surface of your lens and it gums up
your laser so you have to have this very
creative windshield wiper to keep that
clean other options there's a group in
Europe that's looking at using ion
engines where you have a spacecraft that
then has a double-ended ion engine and
so you fly in and you park it next to
your asteroid and you have one ion
engine that's pushing you toward the
asteroid and then you fire another one
at the asteroid and you embed the
exhaust from your ion engine into the
surface and do a very gentle push that
way but of course that takes a very long
time
another thing that's coming up is the
dark mission which is a technology
demonstration mission that NASA is going
to do in a couple of years where they're
going to send a small spacecraft out to
a binary asteroid system and so you've
got the the big asteroid and then you've
got a little moonlit going around it and
they're going to change the orbit of the
little moonlit
around the big asteroid so we're getting
to the point where we're doing these
baby steps engineering and tactile
but are convincing us yeah maybe we can
get there and so those are sort of the
prime candidates right now got it let's
say all of these diversion tactics fail
is there a difference between an impact
that takes place on land versus an
impact that takes place in the water
earth is a water world so a lot of these
things will just hit the ocean at that
point you're concerned about potential
atmospheric effects but we can model
that you just need to get people out of
the vicinity and let it fall potentially
if it's small enough and it turns out
based on research done by some
colleagues of mine about tsunamis it
actually takes a pretty hard punch to
make a tsunami if something hits on land
then it takes a much smaller object to
make a problem when I say big I'm saying
a city killer is gonna be like
football-field-sized so 100 meters 150
meters by 250 meters if it's 100 meters
since made of metal you're gonna make
meteor crator and if meteor crator were
made today Flagstaff ain't coming out
alive so that's that's a city killer if
it's something that's more fluffy more
more fragile then that's going to be an
airburst so if that hit over a populated
area yeah that's gonna burn some houses
down pretty badly that's gonna lower
like multi Megaton nuclear attack on
that city just without the radiation
once you're up to a kilometer that's
gonna be a global disaster because
that's going to kick up a lot of gunk
into the atmosphere and it's going to
change the climate in pretty bad ways at
that point if you look back into the
early 1800s I believe it was the 1820s
there was a super volcanic eruption that
put a bunch of ash up into the upper
atmosphere and blocked out enough Sun
that they didn't have summer in the
northern hemisphere that here crops in
the US failed there was famine it snowed
in new
and that summer in July and that's the
sort of things we would see so there's
big incentives to avoid that kind of
impact yes there is unfortunately they
don't happen very often so that's why
we're planning now is because we we want
to have some thoughts on this we want to
have a plan before anything were to
happen and we're finally as a species at
the point where we're technically
capable of thinking about this and so
it's time to start doing our homework
because we don't want to be reading this
final paper during finals week we we
want to have this solved before we've
got something coming at us this has been
incredibly informative and a little
scary but that's okay thank you very
much